I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess I love the tuxedo and
of course you know that you are now an
internet sensation as hot Jafar yeah
what do you think of that I splattering
right your internet your viral you're an
internet sensation you're hot Jafar
women are far and wide are talking about
you and you're like it's okay no it's
not okay I'm very appreciative and it's
a it's it's I mean it's special well you
know when people are so kind about what
you do or what they see it's you can
only be appreciated
you weren't very classic tonight my guy
no no let me tell you why he went
classic let me tell you why you a
question
where was that with that Paris or London
it was London so he shows up in London
like he just came out of barn like what
are you wearing he came to the London
from hearing like new turned over New
Balance and like like some old khakis I
was like do you do you have no concern
for your career whatsoever the guy
looked at me glad you made an effort so
I said in LA get up you did it right so
innate so you came here correct as hot
Japan I tried to do my best yeah yeah
yeah do you like it I love the tuxedo I
mean there's no getting away from whence
Will Smith gets on you there's no
getting away from this movie is redoing
a classic
were there any fears were you a little
nervous that you were doing an animated
classic this is something that's near
and dear to kids and now adults hearts
you know what know that it's that big
and you know that everybody's gonna sort
of everybody knows about it
and it it it it twisted everything and
it becomes I wasn't nervous because I
thought I'm a most good people yeah
we're passionate about making this film
and I just enjoyed every second of it I
thought you know what I'm just gonna
enjoy it and and it went by like that
six months went by so quick and I
cherish it and by the way you look
better tonight than Will Smith boy pose
there and send a message to all the
folks who have dubbed you HOT Jafar now
go ahead say thanks guys
I think view it's very kind I do my best
as you can see to keep it up cannot
slack
don't ever slack again don't ever slack
again you see the consequences
[Music]